Bumble knows it's hard to start conversations. Hey, no, too basic. Hi there. Still no. What about hello, handsome? Ugh, who knew you could give yourself the ick? That's why Bumble is changing how you start conversations. You can now make the first move or not.
Bumble知道开启对话很难。嘿，不，太基础了。嗨。还是不行。帅哥，你好怎么样？呃，谁知道聊天能让自己这么尴尬？这就是 Bumble 改变你开启对话方式的原因。你现在可以主动打招呼，也可以不主动。
With opening moves, you simply choose a question to be automatically sent to your matches. Then sit back and let your matches start the chat. Download Bumble and try it for yourself. It's really not important to me to have a lot of things to show off. Fancy cars, a giant home. Those things are just not part of who I am,
通过开场白功能，你只需选择一个问题，系统就会自动将其发送给你的配对对象。然后坐下来，让你的配对对象开启聊天。下载 Bumble 并亲自体验一下吧。拥有很多可以炫耀的东西对我来说真的不重要。豪车、大房子。这些东西根本不是我的一部分，
but I've been coached and I've learned through my advisor that it's not one size fits all. Everyone has their own preferences. Everything that I do with Edward Jones is tailored to who I am. Edward Jones. We do money differently. Visit edwardjones.ca slash different.
但我接受过指导，并且通过我的理财顾问了解到，这并非千篇一律。每个人都有自己的偏好。我在爱德华琼斯（Edward Jones）所做的一切都是量身定制的，符合我的特点。爱德华琼斯。我们用不同的方式理财。访问 edwardjones.ca/different。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）。我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。
Hello. Hi. You look so cute. Oh my gosh. Thank you. You look so cute. Oh my gosh, thank you. You look like fall. You kind of dress for fall. I think it's finally fall. I hope it's finally fall.
你好。嗨。你看起来太可爱了。哦，天哪。谢谢。你看起来太可爱了。哦，天哪，谢谢。你看起来像秋天。你的穿着有点像秋天。我想终于到秋天了。我希望终于到秋天了。
I hope so. I'm wearing a flannel. I'm ready for fall. Same. Well, everyone out there listening, listen, don't get upset with us, but we don't have a rewatch this week, but it is because we are doing some big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big,
希望如此。我穿着法兰绒衬衫。我已经准备好迎接秋天了。我也是。好吧，听众朋友们，听着，不要生我们的气，我们这周没有重温剧集，那是因为我们要进行一些非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big there listening, listen, don't get upset with us, but we don't have a rewatch this week, but it is because we are doing some big time prepping. Yes.
非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常重要。是的。最后这四集重温节目，有太多内容我们不想错过，特别是大结局，我们需要额外的一周时间来收集所有的东西。是的。有很多信息，我们想把它做好。一切。是的，有很多信息，我们想把它做好。是的，我们不想仓促。此外，我们还有一位特别的嘉宾将加入我们的演播室
These final four episodes of the rewatch, there was just so much stuff that we didn't want to miss, particularly with the finale, that we needed an extra week to gather everything. Yes. There was a lot of information and we wanted to do it properly. everything. Yes, there is a lot of information and we wanted to do it properly. Yeah, we didn't want to rush. Also, we have a certain special guest that's gonna be joining us in the studio
重温这最后四集时，有太多内容我们不想错过，特别是大结局部分，我们需要额外一周的时间来收集所有资料。是的。有很多信息，我们希望能够妥善处理所有内容。是的，有很多信息，我们想把它做好。是的，我们不想仓促。此外，我们有一位非常特殊的嘉宾将来到录音室加入我们
for our very last episode. And we couldn't record that until he was available. Angela. What? You just gave it away. Or part of it away, you said he. Oh crap. There is, okay, there is a he. Well, we have some really special things planned. Just know that. Yes. And this particular thing is
参加我们的最后一集。在他有空之前，我们无法录制。安吉拉。什么？你刚才说漏嘴了。或者说漏了一部分，你说了他。哦，糟糕。有一个，好吧，有一个他。好吧，我们计划了一些非常特别的事情。只要知道这一点就行了。是的。这件特殊的事情是
something that we've talked about wanting to do for our final episode since we started the podcast. The very beginning. We knew that's how we wanted to end it. So we had to make the time to make that happen. So no rewatch this week, but we do have some things to say. So here we are. First of all, very important, there are two versions of the finale of The Office. We discovered this in our research. There is the version that lives on iTunes.
是我们自开播以来就一直谈论想在最后一集里做的事。一开始。我们从一开始就知道那是我们想要结束的方式。所以我们必须腾出时间来实现它。所以这周不重温，但我们确实有些话要说。所以我们在这里。首先，非常重要的一点是，《办公室》大结局有两个版本。我们在研究中发现了这一点。一个是存在 iTunes 上的版本。
And then there is the version that lives on the DVD. And the one on the DVD is the one that aired. And that is the one that we are going to be breaking down when we get to it. Yes, we want to break down the version that aired originally in 2013 for many reasons, one of which is that it has an extra 7 minutes and 76 seconds of footage. Yes, so if you are rewatching with us, that's what we will be breaking down in two weeks.
另一个是 DVD 上的版本。DVD 上的版本就是播出的版本。这就是我们到达那里时要剖析的版本。是的，我们想要剖析2013年最初播出的版本，原因有很多，其中之一就是它多出了7分76秒的镜头。是的，所以如果你和我们一起重温，这就是我们两周后要剖析的内容。
Yeah. Dave Rogers did tell us that the original version was also on Netflix. So for those of you who have the office on Netflix, you should have the correct version. Well, I also thought that we could share a little bit about what's next for office ladies. People have been asking Angela, what are we doing next? Well, we wanna tell you. That's right, we might be coming to the end of this rewatch, but we are not going anywhere. We are moving right into Office Ladies 6.0. I love it so much.
是的。戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）确实告诉我们原版也在 Netflix 上。所以对于那些在 Netflix 上观看《办公室》的人来说，你们应该有正确的版本。嗯，我还认为我们可以分享一些关于“办公室辣妈”接下来的动态。人们一直在问安吉拉，我们接下来要做什么？嗯，我们想告诉你。没错，我们可能即将结束这次重温，但我们哪儿也不去。我们将直接进入“办公室辣妈” 6.0 版。我太喜欢了。
So perfect. I love 6.0. You guys remember when Michael called Katie, the purse girl, Pam 6.0? Well, we just thought that would be the perfect title for our new Wednesday show. We are going to continue to share all of our fun office stories. We're going to interview people. We're going to deep dive. We're going to mom detective. Yes, there are still a lot of things to cover. So we're going to go deeper into the world of the office and best friendship.
太完美了。我喜欢 6.0 版。大家还记得迈克尔把凯蒂这个包包女孩叫做“帕姆 6.0 版”吗？嗯，我们只是觉得这会是我们新周三节目的完美标题。我们将继续分享所有有趣的办公室故事。我们将采访人们。我们将进行深入探讨。我们将进行妈妈侦探活动。是的，还有很多事情要探讨。所以我们要更深入地了解《办公室》和深厚友谊的世界。
We have an episode that we're working on right now. It's called All About Michael Scott. And it is like a true character breakdown of Michael Scott, and it is absolutely delicious. We have gone through everything, the show Bible, episodes, candy bags, digital clutter, reached out to writers, all in an effort to get to the bottom of Michael Scott and it has been so fun. I hope we'll do that for every character at some point. I can't wait till we get to Creed.
我们正在制作一集。它叫《关于迈克尔·斯科特的一切》，它就像是对迈克尔·斯科特真正的角色剖析，绝对妙不可言。我们浏览了所有内容、剧集圣经、糖果袋、数字杂乱，联系了编剧，所有这些都是为了弄清迈克尔·斯科特的底细，这真是太有趣了。我希望我们能在某个时候为每个角色都这样做。我等不及我们要讲到克里德（Creed）的时候了。
I really want to do Kevin. All about Kevin alone. I do too and Cleven. Exactly. But we also have a very special interview coming up for you guys to kick off Office Ladies 6.0. You've asked for it, we're gonna do it. It's Alison Jones. The person responsible for the cast of The Office.
我真的很想做凯文。只关于凯文。我也想，还有克莱文。没错。但我们也将为您们举办一次非常特别的采访，为“办公室辣妈” 6.0 版拉开序幕。你们一直要求的，我们要做了。她是艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）。负责《办公室》演员阵容的人。
She assembled us and we haven't talked to her yet. And she has a really, really good behind the scenes stories. And talk about digital clutter. Oh. Ladies, she has everything. She has a storage facility in the making of Office Ladies, the podcast. I have reached out to her and she has said to me, you know what, I know the answer to that but it's in my storage facility. And then she'll go to her storage facility on a Saturday and
她把我们聚在一起，我们还没和她谈过呢。她有非常非常好的幕后故事。说到数字杂乱。哦。女士们，她什么都有。在制作“办公室辣妈”播客的过程中，她有一个存储设施。我联系了她，她对我说，你知道吗，我知道那个答案，但它在我的存储设施里。然后她会在周六去她的存储设施，
come back with the answer on a Monday. This woman has a lot of stuff. We can't wait to talk to her. So every Wednesday, you're gonna get Office Ladies 6.0. But that's not all. That is not all. We know how much you guys love the rewatch. It's not going anywhere either. Every Monday, we will be rerunning the rewatch library
周一带着答案回来。这个女人有很多东西。我们迫不及待地想和她谈谈。所以每周三，你都会看到“办公室辣妈” 6.0 版。但这还不够。这还不够。我们知道你们有多喜欢重温节目。它也不会去任何地方。每周一，我们将重新播放重温库
in order with bonus tidbits at the top of every episode. And guess what we're calling that? Should we say it together? I think we should. Okay. Second drink. Come on, it's so perfect. Okay, so Monday's a second drink,
按顺序，每集开头都有一些奖励花絮。你猜我们叫它什么？我们应该一起说吗？我想我们应该。好吧。第二杯。拜托，太完美了。好吧，所以星期一是第二杯，
Wednesday's is Office Lady 6.0. We can't wait. It's really the best of everything. It is. But also, we didn't to leave you guys hanging today. Wait, is that a thing? Hanging? Is that a bad thing?
星期三是“办公室辣妈” 6.0 版。我们迫不及待了。这真的是最好的组合。确实是。但是，我们今天也不想让你们悬着。等等，有这个说法吗？悬着？这是一个不好的说法吗？
Is that an expression about a penis? No, you're safe. No, I think it's about leaving fruit hanging on the tree. You know, something that's delicious that will nourish you. Laying pipe, however. No, Sam, laying pipe is not. But I think, you know what? I'm so sorry.
这是一个关于阴茎的词吗？不，你很安全。不，我认为这是关于把水果挂在树上。你知道的，能滋养你的美味东西。不过，铺设管道。不，萨姆，铺设管道不是。但我想，你知道吗？我很抱歉。
I think in my brain, I was like, is that like saying you're well hung? We don't want to leave you hanging. Well hung. I don't know. Okay, I'm so sorry. Okay. Wait, wait, okay, I'm sorry that I'm taking it in this direction, but I was at my friend's
我想在我的大脑里，我当时想，这就像说你很大吗？我们不想让你悬着。很大。我不知道。好吧，我很抱歉。好吧。等等，等等，好吧，我很抱歉我把话题引向了这个方向，但我上周末在朋友的
birthday party this past weekend and I heard an expression that I had never heard before. What? About penises. Oh my gosh, what? We were doing this very funny quiz about the birthday boy. We were divided- Like a party game? A party game.
生日派对上，我听到了一种我从未听过的表达方式。什么？关于阴茎的。哦，天哪，什么？我们正在做一个非常有趣的关于寿星的测验。我们被分成了——就像一个派对游戏？一个派对游戏。
Okay. And we were being quizzed on facts about the birthday boy. And one of the questions that his wife asked was, is he a shower or a grower? Have you heard this expression? Yeah, of course. I had never heard this expression. What does it mean to be a shower?
好的。我们在接受关于寿星事实的测验。他妻子问的一个问题是，他是长得大还是平时大？你听过这个说法吗？是的，当然。我从来没听过这个说法。平时大是什么意思？
So a shower is if your penis shows really well, just flaccid. So like, could you impress other people? Just in your sweatpants on a walk? No, no, no, no. Nudie. Oh. Just, if you showed it.
所以平时大是指你的阴茎在疲软状态下也表现得很好。就像，你能给其他人留下深刻印象吗？仅仅穿着运动裤散步时？不，不，不，不。裸体。哦。只是，如果你展示了它。
I thought if it's a show-er, then it must look good under clothes. That would technically count. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, are you a show-er? Okay. Like, does it just show well? Okay.
我以为如果是平时大，那它在衣服底下一定看起来很好。这在技术上算数。是的，这说得通。是的，你是平时大吗？好的。就像，它只是表现得很好吗？好吧。
Or, are you a- Does it need a little time? Is it a grower? Is it, does it become impressive as it grows? And this was a question she asked her a group of people? And we had to decide if the birthday boy was a shower or a grower. This is so embarrassing. Well, which was he? He was a grower.
或者，你是一个——它需要一点时间吗？它是长得大吗？它是，它随着生长变得令人印象深刻吗？这是她问一群人的问题吗？我们不得不决定寿星是平时大还是长得大。这太尴尬了。好吧，他是哪种？他是长得大。
All right. Fair, fair. Clearly someone you've known for a long time. This group of friends. Yes, yes. Anyway, a story I wasn't expecting to tell today on this special episode of Office Ladies. Well, guess what? Here's a segue I don't know how to do.
好吧，公平，公平。显然是你认识很久的人。这群朋友。是的，是的。无论如何，这是一个我没料到今天在这个特别的“办公室辣妈”节目中讲述的故事。好吧，你猜怎么着？这是一个我不知道该如何过渡的转折。
You guys all know we love the Lazy Genius. I'm sure she's thrilled to be associated with this episode now. We thought Kendra Adachi could help us out today. She has a new book coming out. It's called The Plan, and we thought we could give you a sneak peek. And of course, you guys that listen here all the time know that Kendra is on the Office Ladies Network, and we just adore her. She is a two-time New York Times bestselling author.
你们都知道我们喜欢懒人天才（Lazy Genius）。我相信她现在对与这一集产生联系感到兴奋。我们认为肯德拉·安达奇（Kendra Adachi）今天可以帮我们一把。她有一本新书要出版。它叫《计划》（The Plan），我们觉得我们可以给你一个先睹为快。当然，在这里一直听节目的你们都知道肯德拉在“办公室辣妈”网络上，我们非常崇拜她。她是《纽约时报》两次畅销书作家。
Jenna and I got an advanced copy of her new book, The Plan. It's seriously a game changer. It is. Look, we all struggle with how to best manage our busy schedules, but Kendra gives us actually relatable tools, not just like fancy ideas that you can't use. Her book comes out next Tuesday, October 8th,
珍娜和我拿到了她的新书《计划》的预先副本。这绝对是一个游戏规则改变者。确实是。听着，我们都在为如何最好地管理繁忙的日程而苦恼，但肯德拉给我们提供了真正切合实际的工具，而不仅仅是你用不上的花哨想法。她的书将于下周二，即 10 月 8 日出版，
and don't get mad at Kendra, but in reading the plan in advance of it coming out, this was one of the reasons why I called you, Angela, and I said, I think we need an extra week to prep these last few episodes. Because reading this book about how to organize things and get everything done, it also included this perspective and this permission to say, I can't get it all done on this timeline. I need to reorganize. I was so relieved when you called and said that because I was white-knuckling it, trying to get everything done.
不要生肯德拉的气，但在新书出版前阅读《计划》时，这是我打电话给安吉拉的原因之一，我说，我想我们需要额外一周的时间来准备这最后几集。因为阅读这本关于如何组织事情并完成所有事情的书，它也包括了这种观点和这种许可，即说，我无法在这样的时间表上完成所有事情。我需要重新组织。当你打电话说那个时，我松了一口气，因为我一直在咬紧牙关，试图把所有事情都做好。
I don't want to miss anything. I don't either. The finale is too big. And this is a busy time of year. It is. It's end of the year. We just had all of the back to school night stuff. And then it's the holidays. And we have this big work milestone of five years. Also, Cassie brought up something so great the other day.
我不想错过任何东西。我也不想。大结局太盛大了。这是一个一年中繁忙的时期。确实是。这是一年的尽头。我们刚刚经历所有开学之夜的事情。然后是假期。我们有五年的重大工作里程碑。此外，凯西前几天提出了一个非常棒的观点。
She was like, I don't want us to not mark how big this moment is and to take time with it. Yeah. So we know that you all can relate to the stress, but also the excitement of a busy chapter of life. And I think that one of the things we love about Kendra's book is that it's really written with those moments in mind, those seasons.
她说，我不希望我们不庆祝这个时刻有多么重大，并不花时间去体会它。是的。所以我们知道你们都能体会到生活忙碌阶段的压力，但也伴随着兴奋。我认为我们喜欢肯德拉书的原因之一是它确实是带着这些时刻、这些季节编写的。
Yes. So why don't we take a break, and when we come back, we're going to let Kendra tell you all about her book herself. She's even going to read you the first chapter. I love it. And then we'll be back after the second break to wrap things up. ["Dreams of a New World"]
所以我们休息一下，当我们回来时，我们将让肯德拉亲自向大家介绍她的书。她甚至会给你读第一章。我太喜欢了。然后我们在第二个休息后回来做个总结。["Dreams of a New World"]
Are you Dave, a claims-free, hybrid driving university grad who signed up online? Well, Dave, this jingles for you. Who says with T.D. Insurance? Because he's a claims-free, up online? Well Dave, this jingles for you. Not Dave, no problem. TD Insurance has over 30 ways to save on home and auto. So, save like only you can at tdinsurance.com slash ways to save. TD, ready for you. Hi there, you're listening to the Lazy Genius podcast. I'm Kendra Adachi and I'm here to help you be a genius
你是戴夫吗，一个无索赔、驾驶混动车、在网上注册的大学毕业生？好吧，戴夫，这个铃声是为你准备的。谁说用道明保险（TD Insurance）？因为他是一个无索赔的、网上的？好吧，戴夫，这个铃声是为你准备的。不是戴夫，没关系。道明保险在房屋和汽车保险方面有 30 多种省钱方法。所以，像只有你能做的那样在 tdinsurance.com/waystosave 上省钱。道明，为你准备。你好，你正在收听懒人天才播客。我是肯德拉·安达奇，我在这里帮助你成为一个天才
about the things that matter and lazy about the things that don't. Today's episode 381, the real reason planning is hard. It's not what you think. And I'm really excited to bring you into the light of the productivity industrial complex that we are all under. I do promise it's more exciting than that just sounded. The best way for me to explain the real reason planning is hard
关于重要的事情，对不重要的事情保持懒惰。今天的第 381 集，计划难的真正原因。不是你想的那样。我真的很兴奋能带你了解我们都身处其中生产力工业综合体的光明。我保证这比听起来更刺激。我解释计划难的真正原因的最佳方式
is using words that I already wrote that were edited many times over and are currently being printed into my new book, The Plan. Manage your time like a lazy genius. We are into compassionate time management around here, but it's not just pep talks and high fives. We love those things too. We are practical and kind, but we're also educated. We are trying to understand why we struggle with time management, why we own so many planners, why we never feel like we're doing enough. And even if we finally have let that go,
就是使用我之前写过的话，经过多次编辑，目前正被印进我的新书《计划》中。像懒人天才一样管理你的时间。我们这里追求的是富有同情心的的时间管理，但这不仅仅是打气和击掌。我们也喜欢那些东西。我们务实而善良，但我们也受过教育。我们试图理解为什么我们在时间管理上苦苦挣扎，为什么我们拥有如此多的规划师，为什么我们永远觉得自己做得不够。即使我们终于放下了这一点，
we still struggle against the tide of everyone else making us feel bad for our choices. Basically, the problem is not you. And today I'm gonna show you why by reading you the first chapter in my new book out October 8th called The Plan. Here it is. I grew up going to the mall.
我们仍然在与其他人让我们因选择而感到糟糕的潮流作斗争。基本上，问题不在于你。今天我将通过为你朗读我 10 月 8 日出版的新书《计划》的第一章来向你展示原因。给你。我是逛商场长大的。
If you're of an age where you're not sure what a mall is, now is a good time to tell you that I am in perimenopause. I've never downloaded TikTok, and I didn't have a cell phone until I was 17. Not because my parents were strict, but because people didn't have them yet. Consider yourself generationally warned. Back to the mall. I loved spending time there as a kid.
如果你处于不确定商场是什么的年龄，现在是告诉你我正处于围绝经期（perimenopause）的好时机。我从未下载过 TikTok，直到 17 岁我才有手机。不是因为我的父母很严厉，而是因为当时人们还没有手机。请在代际上警告自己。回到商场。我小时候很喜欢在那里度过时光。
The mall is where I got my ears pierced, where I awkwardly hung out with a boy I liked, where I ate a truckload of Cinnabons, where I awkwardly hung out with a boy I liked, where I ate a truckload of Cinnabons, where I learned to confidently walk past Victoria's Secret without looking or breaking stride. Say you grew up in purity culture without saying you grew up in purity culture. But my favorite thing about the mall was the You Are Here map. Holy moly, I still love that thing. Not only do you have the stores organized by category on a giant screen,
商场是我穿耳洞的地方，是我和喜欢的男孩尴尬闲逛的地方，是我吃了一卡车肉桂卷的地方，是我和喜欢的男孩尴尬闲逛的地方，是我吃了一卡车肉桂卷的地方，是我学会自信地走过维多利亚的秘密而不看一眼或打破步伐的地方。可以说你在纯洁文化中长大，而不用说你在纯洁文化中长大。但我最喜欢商场的是“您在此”地图。天哪，我仍然喜欢那个东西。你不仅在巨大的屏幕上按类别组织了商店，
but you also have a beautiful red dot that tells you exactly where you are. Say you're in Enneagram One without saying you're in Enneagram One. You can see everything, and you can see yourself. Chances are you would like that for your life too. Wouldn't it be amazing to see everything at a glance so you can quickly chart a route to an imagined future where life is beautiful and under control? That's probably why you keep buying planners.
而且你还有一个漂亮的红点，可以准确地告诉你你在哪里。可以说你是九型人格一号，而不用说你是九型人格一号。你可以看到一切，你可以看到你自己。你可能也希望你的生活是这样的。一眼就能看到一切，从而能够快速规划一条通往想象中生活美丽且在掌控之中的未来的路线，不是很棒吗？这可能就是你一直买规划师的原因。
A planner is the closest thing we have to a you are here map to that bird's eye view. You want your day, week, month, quarter, year, to-do lists, tracking bubbles, words of gratitude, meal plans, and five-year goals all available at a glance. You get your next new planner, and you spend hours setting it up, answering questions about what you want to accomplish
规划师是我们拥有的最接近“您在此”地图的东西，可以鸟瞰全局。你希望你的每一天、每一周、每个月、每季度、每年、待办事项列表、追踪气泡、感恩的话语、膳食计划和五年目标都一目了然。你得到了你的下一个新规划师，你花了几个小时来设置它，回答关于你想完成什么的问题
and what habits you want to begin, and maybe even trying your hand at a doodle or two. Once you're done, you let out a deep, gratified sigh. There it is. There's everything at once. Life is going to be better now. But then, much to your chagrin, life happens again, and you can't keep up with your plan.
以及你想开始什么习惯，甚至可能尝试画一两幅涂鸦。完成后，你会发出深深的、满足的叹息。就是这样。一切都在一瞬间。生活现在会变得更好了。但是，令你懊恼的是，生活再次发生，你无法跟上你的计划。
You manage what you can for as long as you can, biding your time until the next opportunity to reset and see everything at once. The beginning of summer, the school year, January, and you repeat. I bet you've been repeating for a long time, yet you're still drowning. Why?
你能管理多少就管理多少，只要你能坚持，等待下一个重置和一眼看清一切的机会。夏天的开始，学年，一月份，然后你重复。我敢打赌你已经重复了很久，但你仍然在溺水。为什么？
Everything at once is the problem, not the solution. Everything at once is why you push your palms against your eyeballs multiple times a day. Everything at once is why you doom scroll in the bathroom, hoping no one notices you're gone. They will. Everything at once is why you listen to an audio book while cooking dinner,
一切同时发生是问题所在，而不是解决方案。一切同时发生是你一天多次用手掌压住眼球的原因。一切同时发生是你在浴室里疯狂刷手机、希望没人注意到你离开的原因。他们会的。一切同时发生是你在做晚饭时听有声读物的原因，
while helping somebody with their homework, while wearing microfiber socks, because somebody on the internet said it was like sweeping. Everything at once is not how we're meant to live. Before you lose hope, let me be the Robin Williams to your Matt Damon and tell you that it's not your fault. It's not your fault. It's not your fault. You are not the reason you're drowning. You are not the reason everything at once doesn't work. You are not the reason time management principles aren't sticking. The reason is far beyond you. Let's sit crisscross applesauce and do a little history corner. Okay. Remember the Industrial Revolution?
同时帮某人做作业，同时穿着超细纤维袜子，因为互联网上的某个人说这就像扫地。一切同时发生不是我们生活的意义。在你失去希望之前，让我成为你的罗宾·威廉姆斯（Robin Williams），你的马特·达蒙（Matt Damon），并告诉你这不是你的错。这不是你的错。这不是你的错。你不是你溺水的原因。你不是一切同时发生不起作用的原因。你不是时间管理原则没有坚持下去的原因。原因远超于你。让我们盘腿坐下，做一个小历史角落。好吧。还记得工业革命吗？
America quickly went from, whoa, coal to OMG, gas is amazing, to have you heard about this electricity thing? The West got bigger and better and consequently went cuckoo for productivity. This guy's factory had to beat that guy's factory. And he did that by making stuff faster than the other guy did. When the digital revolution happened, it gave us more the computers and AOL InstaMessenger. We were given the promise of more time. Technology would create efficient production for us, freeing us to do other presumably more enjoyable things.
美国迅速从，哇，煤炭到天哪，天然气太神奇了，到你听说过这个叫电的东西吗？西方变得更大更好，因此对生产力变得疯狂。这家伙的工厂必须打败那家伙的工厂。他通过比另一个人更快地制造东西来做到这一点。当数字革命发生时，它给了我们更多的计算机和 AOL 及时通信。我们得到了拥有更多时间的承诺。技术将为我们创造高效的生产，释放我们去做其他大概更愉快的事情。
Amazing. However, that digital revolution happened so fast that we never disentangled ourselves from the industrial revolution's culture of productivity. Unfortunately for us, that same technology Unfortunately for us, that same technology incidentally made the productivity obsession worse. It makes me think of that scene in Sabrina when Harrison Ford, Linus, and Julia Ormond, Sabrina take a helicopter to board a private jet to fly to Martha's Vineyard for the day. Once they're buckled into their plush seats, Linus immediately begins working, looking at nothing but the reports in front of him. Sabrina, frustrated by his indifference to the present moment, asks, Don't you ever look out the window? I don't have time. What about all
太棒了。然而，那场数字革命发生得太快了，以至于我们从未让自己摆脱工业革命的生产力文化。不幸的是，对于我们来说，这项相同技术不幸的是，对于我们来说，这项相同技术顺便让生产力痴迷变得更糟。这让我想起《龙凤配》（Sabrina）中的那一幕，哈里森·福特（Harrison Ford）饰演的利纳斯（Linus）和朱莉娅·奥蒙德（Julia Ormond）饰演的萨布丽娜（Sabrina）乘直升机登上私人飞机，飞往玛莎葡萄园岛过一天。一旦他们扣好毛绒座位的安全带，利纳斯立即开始工作，看着面前的报告。萨布丽娜对他对当下的冷漠感到沮丧，问，你从来不看窗外吗？我没有时间。那我们乘直升机节省的所有时间呢？他尴尬地停顿了一下。我把它存起来了。不，你没有。她回答说。各位，我们也没有。事实上，对生产力的痴迷深深地融入了我们的文化中，以至于我们生活在生产力工业综合体中。尽管我在任何形式的社会研究课上都没有蒸蒸日上，但请允许我解释一下这意味着什么。工业综合体本质上是一个行业与社会中的某些元素处于反馈回路中。公共和私营部门变得如此交织，以至于将它们分开几乎是不可能的。这种联系往往与对社会本身最好的东西背道而驰。让我们以婚礼为例。2023 年，美国婚礼行业的价值超过 700 亿美元，平均婚礼费用
the time we've saved taking the helicopter? He awkwardly pauses. I'm storing it up. No, you're not. She replies. And y'all, we're not either. In fact, the obsession with productivity is so deeply woven into our culture that we live in a productivity industrial complex. Even though I did not thrive in any form of social studies class, allow me to explain what that means. An industrial complex is essentially when an industry is in a feedback loop with some element in society. The public and private sectors become so intertwined that separating them is almost impossible. And that connection is often at odds with what is best for society itself. Let's take weddings as an example. The US wedding industry was worth over $70 billion in 2023 with the average wedding costing
刚刚超过三万。我不是在敲击任何人的选择。如果你想要一场盛大的婚礼，享受它。但是，如果婚礼行业开始推行这样的想法：更小、更简单、更便宜的婚礼很棒，你不需要跟风，考虑 Instagram 值得分享的元素，或者以任何方式留下深刻印象。如果这个想法生根发芽，人们会花更少的钱，行业就会受苦。因此，尽管对人们来说举行他们喜欢的任何婚礼可能在集体上更好，但婚礼行业不能鼓励这一点。因此，我们将继续拥有杂志、
just shy of 30 grand. I'm not knocking anyone's choices. And if you want an all out wedding, enjoy it. But what if the wedding industry began pushing the idea that smaller, simpler, less expensive weddings were great, that you didn't need to follow the trends, think about Instagram worthy elements or be impressive in any way. If that idea took root, people would spend less and the industry would suffer. So even though it might be collectively better for folks to have whatever wedding they like, the wedding industry cannot encourage that. Therefore, we will continue to have magazines,
博客和社交媒体告诉我们我们应该想要什么样的婚礼。这就是婚礼工业综合体。另一个例子是监狱工业综合体。许多人正在倡导司法系统的改革，这将导致监狱中的人数减少。然而，美国监狱行业的年收入超过 100 亿美元。此外，监狱系统中的被监禁个人通过商品和服务产生收入。因此，尽管司法改革和监狱改革对社会有益，但由于司法系统与行业的交织如此深厚，监狱工业综合体使它们极其困难。生产力也发生了同样的事情。
blogs, and social media telling us what kind of wedding we should want. That's the wedding industrial complex. Another example is the prison industrial complex. Many are championing reform in the judicial system, which would lead to fewer people in prisons. However, the U.S. prison industry makes over 10 billion a year. And incarcerated individuals in the prison system generate revenue from goods and services on top of that. So even though justice reform and prison reform would be beneficial for society, the prison industrial complex makes them extremely difficult because of how deeply entwined the justice system is with the industry. The same has happened with productivity.
当前的优化、效率和成功的生产力范式是如此普遍和意料之中，以至于不言而喻，我们需要资源和结构来维护该范式。来源和结构来维护该范式。全球生产力行业预计在 2024 年产生 790 亿美元。这是很多亿。只要生产力重要，市场就会繁荣。只要市场繁荣，生产力就会继续留在文化对话中。蛇只是吃自己的尾巴，同时也变得非常富有。
The current productivity paradigm of optimization, efficiency, and success is so pervasive and so expected that it stands to reason we need resources and structures to uphold that paradigm. sources and structures to uphold that paradigm. The global productivity industry is projected to generate $79 billion in 2024. That's a lot of billions. As long as productivity matters, the marketplace will thrive. And as long as the marketplace thrives, productivity will remain in the cultural conversation. The snake just eats its tail while also becoming very rich.
那条蛇不希望你对生活感到满足。那蛇希望你不断尝试、奋斗、规划、梦想，并怀疑这一切是否有效。那蛇希望你，正如那句可怕的俗语所说，死后休息。因为当你继续前进时，你花钱并保持行业继续运转。
And that snake does not want you to be content with your life. That snake wants you to keep trying and striving and planning and dreaming and wondering if any of it is working. That snake wants you to, as the horrible saying goes, rest when you're dead. Because when you keep going, you spend money and you keep the industry going too.
正如我的朋友、《纽约时报》畅销书作家凯利·柯林肯（Kelly Corrigan）曾经对我说的那样，满足感不会刺激经济活动。简而言之，你对任何程度的生产力的全神贯注都不是你的错。早在你翻阅第一个规划师之前，它就已经融入了系统中。这并不是唯一融入系统的事情。现在是女性历史角落的时间。白人女性直到 1920 年才能投票。黑人女性直到 1965 年才能投票。直到 1978 年，女性因怀孕而被解雇在法律上是合法的。
As my friend and New York Times bestselling author, Kelly Corrigan once said to me, contentment doesn't stimulate economic activity. In short, your preoccupation with productivity to whatever level is not your fault. It was built into the system long before you were flipping through your first planner. And that's not the only thing that's built into the system. Now it's time for Women's History Corner. White women couldn't vote until 1920. Black women couldn't vote until 1965. Women could legally be fired for being pregnant until 1978.
女性在相同工作中的收入仍然比男性少。哦，太有趣了，我们可以将一点隐含的父权制扔进生产力工业综合体中。本质上，女性生活在一个由白人男性制造的世界中，由白人男性的规则支持，为了白人男性的利益，我们没有足够的声音来看待被倾听的许多切实结果。现在例外随处可见，但总的来说，男性不被期望做每一顿饭，做所有的洗衣工作，记住每一个生日，恢复身材，为了孩子呆在家或根本不生孩子。他们不会因为单身而感到羞耻。他们不担心
Women still get paid less than men for the same jobs. Oh fun, we can throw a little implicit patriarchy into the productivity industrial complex. Essentially, women are in a white man-made world that's supported by white men's rules for the benefit of white men, and we haven't had a voice for long enough to see many tangible results of being heard. Now exceptions exist everywhere, but generally speaking, men aren't expected to make every meal, do all the laundry, remember every birthday, get their body back, stay at home for the sake of the kids or have kids at all. They're not shamed for being single. They don't worry
晚上去跑步，或者自动拿着钥匙穿过停车场。男性不会每天都生活在男性为主导的领域中不被倾听的疲惫和不公正中。他们不是去学校接生病孩子离开工作的人。男性通常不会承担记住家庭无形生态系统每一个细节的责任。男性不会被告知微笑、冷静下来、打扫干净或排好队。男性不会每 28 天流血一次。你在这里看到差距了吗？生产力行业赚了很多钱
about going for a run at night or automatically walk through a parking deck with their keys between their fingers. Men don't daily exist with the weariness and injustice of not being listened to in a male-dominated field. They aren't the ones to leave work to get a sick kid from school. Men typically do not take it upon themselves to remember every detail of a home's invisible ecosystem. Men aren't told to smile, calm down, clean up, or get in line. Men don't bleed every 28 days. Do you see the disparity here? The productivity industry makes a ton of money
教导我们生产，这一切都在一种将我们置于女性生产标准惊人高的文化中。我们别无选择，只能按照由男性编写并为男性编写的规则和策略生活。这令人筋疲力尽，是时候换一种方式了。”这就是《计划》第一章的结束。
teaching us to produce all within a culture that holds us to a startlingly high standard of what a woman's production should be. We have no choice but to live according to the rules and strategies written by and for men. It's exhausting and it's time for another way." And that completes the first chapter of the plan.
我并不是故意把它弄得像个预告片一样，就像你知道的，像一个戏剧性的电影预告片。那是第一章的结束。但本书的其余部分完全阐述了另一种方式。它充满了有用的原则来改变你的想法，你可以在规划中使用的可行策略，字面意思是现在，然后是一整节标记的打气话，当你需要提醒什么重要时。计划难的真正原因与你无关，各位。所以让我们让它更容易。让我们让它关于正确的事情，同情、满足、我们可以今天使用的好实践
I didn't mean for this to be so much of a tease, like know, like a dramatic movie trailer. That is the end of chapter one. But the rest of the book completely lays out that other way. It is full of helpful principles to change how you think, actionable strategies that you can use in your planning, literally right now, and then a whole section of labeled pep talks for when you need a reminder about what matters. The real reason planning is hard has nothing to do with you y'all. So let's make it easier. Let's make it about the right things, compassion, contentment, good practices we can use today
以及当我们精心制定的计划不起作用时的善良。另外，再次，很多可行的现实生活帮助。我迫不及待地想让你阅读它。现在，如果你已经订购了这本书，不要忘记在 thelazygeniuscollective.com/theplan 与 LG 团队一起注册你的预购。当你这样做时，你可以获得每周的打气话
and kindness when our well laid plans don't work out. Plus, again, lots of actionable real life help. and kindness when our well-laid plans don't work out. Plus again, lots of actionable real life help. I cannot wait for you to read it. Now, if you've already ordered the book, don't forget to register your pre-order with team LG at the lazygeniuscollective.com slash the plan. When you do that, you get access to a weekly pep talk
以书面和音频形式，在 2024 年余下的时间里每周一发送给你。我是在我们周围的生活发生时写它们的。所以希望所有这些都会让人感到非常季节性和相关，无论你正在处理什么。我迫不及待地想让你在等待书发布的同时开始体验它们。
in both written and audio form, delivered to you every single Monday for the rest of 2024. I am writing them as life happens around us. So hopefully all of them will feel wildly seasonal and relevant to whatever you're dealing with. I can't wait for you to start experiencing them while you wait for the book to release.
所以请在 thelazygeniuscollective.com/theplan 注册你的预购。所以我们希望大家喜欢这个，各位。听畅，我们真的希望肯德拉的书成为畅销书，因为，嗯，我们认为她实至名归。是的。预购是实现这一目标的重要途径。我一定会把链接放在我们的“办公室辣妈”播客故事中，这样你们就知道确切的
So register your pre-order at thelazygeniuscollective.com slash the plan. So we hope you enjoyed that, everybody. Listen, we just really want Kendra's book to be a bestseller because, well, we think it deserves it. Yeah. Pre-orders are a big way to make that happen. I will definitely put a link in our Office Ladies podcast stories so you guys know exactly
如何获得肯德拉的书《计划》。绝对，绝对要去 thelazygeniuscollective.com/theplan 注册你的预购，因为那样你就可以得到她的打气话。我们很喜欢打气话。我喜欢书中的打气话。嗯哼。随着我结束今年，我希望每周都能得到肯德拉的打气话。我真的希望如此。你知道我也订阅了肯德拉的时事通讯吗。我也是。他们太搞笑了，安吉拉。她太搞笑了，她像我一样是个大书虫，我想告诉你一件事。什么？我读过一本书，因为肯德拉在她的时事通讯中推荐了它。
how to get Kendra's book, The Plan. And definitely, definitely go to thelazygeniuscollective.com slash the plan to register your pre-order because then you get her pep talks. We are loving the pep talks. I love the pep talks in the book. Mm-hmm. I want a pep talk every week from Kendra as I finish up this year. I really do. You know I'm also subscribed to Kendra's newsletter. Me too. They are so funny Angela. She is so funny and she's a big reader like me and I want to tell you something. What? There is a book that I read because Kendra featured it in her newsletter.
如果你还记得的话，这对你来说是一个真正的改变。这是一部奇幻小说。里面有龙。你不得不了解新的世界和新的规则。我真的这样做了。事情是这样的。好吧，所以我的朋友阿德里安（Adrienne）给我寄了这本书。它叫《第四翼》（Fourth Wing）。她把它寄给我了。
It was a real departure for you, if I remember. It was a fantasy novel. It has dragons in it. You had to learn about new worlds and new rules. I really did. Here's what happened. Okay, so my friend Adrienne sent me this book. It's called The Fourth Wing. She sent it to me.
我没读。我爱阿德里安。我正要说。她知道我不喜欢奇幻。阿德里安现在知道你会说，谢谢，放一边吧。我们会发短信谈论它。她喜欢奇幻小说。
I didn't read it. I love Adrienne. I was gonna say. She knows that I don't like fantasy. Adrienne now knows that you're like, thanks, set aside. We would text about it. She loves fantasy novels.
她说，我知道你说你不喜欢这些书。我把它寄给你。我把我的副本寄给你，因为我坚信你会喜欢的。没读。然后李（Lee）给我买了这个作为圣诞礼物。你现在有两本了？我有两本。我有两本。每年圣诞节，李都会寻找可能是我平时阅读范围之外的书籍。我喜欢这个传统。这是他送给我的圣诞礼物之一。所以现在我有两本。还是没读。但这会让你知道我有多信任肯德拉。她写了这本书
And she was like, I know you say you don't like these books. I'm sending it to you. I'm sending you my copy because I so believe you're gonna love it. Didn't read it. Then Lee bought it for me for Christmas. You now have two copies? I have two copies. I had two copies. Every Christmas Lee looks for books that are maybe something outside of what I would normally read. I love this tradition. This was one of the books he gave me for Christmas. So now I have two copies of it. Still didn't read it. But this will let you know how much I trust Kendra. She wrote about this book
在她的时事通讯中。所以我崩溃了。我读了。安吉拉，这是我今年最喜欢的书之一。我应该读吗？是的。我的意思是，你有一本多出来的副本。我当然有。我送给你。所以它是关于这样一个世界的，你知道的？我的意思是，你一说龙我就心动了。是的。这里有这个女孩，她不得不去接受军事训练。并不是每个人都能在训练中活下来，安吉拉。哦，好吧。她想成为图书馆系统的一部分，在那里他们记录事情。
in her newsletter. So I broke down. I read it. Angela, it was one of my favorite books of the year. Should I read it? Yes. I mean, you have an extra copy. I sure do. I'll give it to you. So it's about like this world, you know? I mean, you had me at Dragon's. Yes. And there's this gal, and she has to go to this military training. And not everybody lives through the training, Angela. Oh, okay. She wanted to be part of the library system where they document things.
她喜欢记录事情，但她的母亲强迫她参军。重点是你最终会与一条龙配对，然后你就会成为一名战斗机飞行员。就像你是战斗机飞行员，但你的飞机是一条龙。哦，亲爱的，你不需要向我解释龙怎么能成为你的飞机，好吗？
She loves to document things, but her mother is forcing her to go into the military. And the point of it is you eventually get matched with a dragon and then you become a fighter. It's like you're a fighter pilot, but your plane is a dragon. Oh, honey, you don't have to break down to me how a dragon can be your plane, okay?
我不需要？不。因为有一整部关于龙的剧集。《龙之家族》（House of the Dragon）。对。人们骑着它们吗？是的。哦。
I don't? No. Because there's a whole show about dragons. House of Dragons. Right. Do people ride them? Yes. Oh.
它们投入战斗。好的。骑在它们的龙上。好的。是的。嗯，这本书也很性感。它性感吗？它性感。
And they go into battle. Okay. On their dragons. Okay. Yes. Well, this book is also very Soxie. It's Soxie? It's Soxie.
就像有，呼嘿，呼嘿正在发生。学院里的每个人都很火辣，他们总是互相勾搭。这是他们发泄的方式。所以它是一本性感的、就像拿着我的龙一样的书。是的， exatamente。她就是这么说的。
Like there's, hoo hee, hoo hee's happening. Everybody at the Academy is hot and they all hook up with each other all the time. It's how they blow off steam. Okay. So it is a sexy, like hold my dragon. Yeah, exactly. That's what she said.
抱歉。我不得不这样做。珍娜，我有个问题。如果你，你认为《龙之家族》是关于什么的，如果他们不骑着它们？哦，我觉得，这是一个好问题，萨姆。我以为，你知道的，另一部叫什么来着？《权力的游戏》（Game of Thrones）？
Sorry. I had to. Jenna, I have a question. If you, what do you think house of Dragon is about if they're not riding them? Oh, I thought, it's a good question, Sam. I thought that, you know, and what was the other show called? Game of Thrones?
另一个是什么？天哪！我受不了你。权力的游戏。《权力的游戏》。它主要关于孵化和拥有龙。不，不是的。我不记得有什么。根本不主要是关于那个的。你不记得有人骑着它吗？
What was the other? Good Lord! I can't, I can't with you. Game of Thrones. It was mostly about just hatching and having the dragons. No, it wasn't. I don't remember any. It's not mostly about that at all. You don't remember anyone riding it?
冬日将至怎么样？像行尸走肉一样的 hordes 要来杀所有人怎么样？它以她骑在龙身上结束。不，不，我没有。这就是我要说的。《权力的游戏》中的龙故事情节。该故事线的大部分内容只是关于鸡蛋、孵化、拥有它们以及保护它们。不，不，不。是的。它们重新觉醒了。
How about winter is coming? How about like the hordes of like the walking dead or coming to kill everyone? It ended with her riding in the dragon. No, no, I didn't. This is what I'm saying. I'm saying the dragon storyline of Game of Thrones. The majority of that storyline was simply about the eggs and the hatching and then the having of them and the protecting of them. No, no, no. Yeah. They're reawakened.
一个女士，几个人在《权力的游戏》中骑龙。这是在剧集的后期吗？因为我谈论的是我的经历，见鬼——哦，哦，对不起。哦，等等。对不起。不，等等，等等。如果你只看了前三集，我想它确实只关于宝宝。没错。
One lady, several people ride dragons in Game of Thrones. Is it later in the series? Because I'm talking about my experience of freaking- Oh, oh, I'm sorry. Oh, wait. I'm sorry. No, wait, wait. If you only watched the first three episodes, I suppose it is only about the babies. Exactly.
对不起。我知道这里发生了什么。我又被“约翰·威克”了。她看了某部作品的前 15 分钟，然后说，它是关于孵化的。就是孵化。是的，新问题。你看过多少《权力的游戏》？好吧，我想我坚持看完了第一季的很大一部分。
I'm sorry. I know what's happened here. I've just been John Wick'd again. She's watched the first 15 minutes of something and then is like, it's about the hatching. It's the hatching. Yeah, new question. How much Game of Thrones have you seen? Okay, I think I made it through a good portion of the first season.
我很抱歉。我知道这里发生什么了。我刚刚又被“疾速追杀”了一回。她看了某个节目头15分钟，然后就说，这跟孵化有关。这就是孵化。好吧，换个新问题。你看了多少《权力的游戏》？好吧，我想我大概看完了第一季的很大一部分。
I... What is this, like 10 minutes an episode? No, the guy who, the young blonde guy became king. Joffrey? Yeah, he decapitated the man that I was loving to follow. The main guy. Sean, what's his name? Sean. The daughter saw it. No, she didn't see it. People wouldn't let her see it. But it's- I mean, his head was on a spike for weeks. I think she eventually saw it. Ned Stark. Yeah.
我……这是什么，一集10分钟左右？不对，那个男的，那个年轻的金发男当了国王。乔佛里？对，他把我最喜欢的那个男的给斩首了。那个主要角色。肖，他叫什么名字？肖。女儿看到了。不，她没看到。大家不让她看。但——我的意思是，他的头被挂在长矛上好几个星期。我想她最后还是看到了。奈德·史塔克。对。
Yes, Ned Stark. Okay. I was a real big fan of the Stark family. And when they decapitated the patriarch of that family. That's when you gave up? That is early. Okay, wait, there was, this is really when they lost me, was that there was a whole new land that was introduced. Remember when the woman started being like red and... Do you remember?
对，奈德·史塔克。好吧。我真的是史塔克家族的超级粉丝。当他们把那个家族的大家长斩首时。这就是你放弃的时候？那可真够早的。好吧，等等，还有，真正让我粉转黑的是，里面引入了一片全新大陆。还记得那个女人开始变得像红色一样……你还记得吗？
Game of Thrones is constantly introducing new land and new people. Yeah. They sailed there and then she would have, there were visions, I think. Yes, she's kind of a witch. Okay, I was out. Okay.
《权力的游戏》一直在引入新的土地和新的人物。对。他们航海去了那里，然后她会有一些幻觉，我觉得。对，她有点像个女巫。好吧，我弃剧了。好吧。
How far did I get? How far is that? Is that season two? That's two out of 10, maybe. Okay, I was out. How far did I get? How far is that? Is that season two? That's two out of ten, maybe. Like, you've seen an eighth of the show. Did I make it to season two? Yes.
我看到哪了？那算看到哪了？那是第二季吗？大概是十集里看了两集吧。好吧，我弃剧了。我看到哪了？那算看到哪了？那是第二季吗？大概是十集里看了两集吧。就像是，你只看了这部剧的八分之一。我看到第二季了吗？是的。
I did? I think so. Well, there you go. That's not so bad. Wait, let me tell you. But I'll tell you, in those episodes, I don't remember anybody flying on a dragon. Melisandre, you made it, too. Oh, my god. How do I find that you, in those episodes, I don't remember anybody flying on a dragon. Melisandre, you made it too.
我看了？我想是的。好吧，那就这样。那还算不错。等等，让我告诉你。不过我得告诉你，在那些集数里，我不记得有人骑着龙飞。梅丽珊翠，你也坚持到了。哦，天哪。我怎么发现你，在那些集数里，我不记得有人骑着龙飞。梅丽珊翠，你也坚持到了。
Oh my God, how do I find that out, Sam? Jenna, if it makes you feel better, I've never seen Game of Thrones. It does make me feel better. Cassie, it does. Cassie, what the hell? It does make me feel better. I tried to watch the pilot twice
哦，天哪，我怎么才能发现这一点呢，萨姆？珍娜，如果这能让你感觉好受点的话，我从来没看过《权力的游戏》。这确实让我感觉好受点。卡西，真的。卡西，搞什么鬼？这确实让我感觉好受点。我试过看两次试播集
and it just was so unsettling. And too many names. And it didn't hook me. Yeah. It's a lot of names and I love that. I love it. Cassie, first of her name. Okay. Lover of cats.
而且实在太让人不安了。名字太多了。而且没能吸引我。是的。名字确实很多，我超喜欢。我太喜欢了。卡西，人称卡西一世。好吧。猫咪爱好者。
Grower of plants. Shower of plants. Shower of plants. Thank you. Hell. Cassie's plants show well. Nicely done. Yeah, she shows up in season two. Thank you. Hell! Ha ha ha. Cassie's plants show well. Ha ha ha.
植物种植者。植物展示者。植物展示者。谢谢。见鬼。卡西的植物展示得很好。干得漂亮。对，她在第二季出场了。谢谢。见鬼！哈哈哈哈。卡西的植物展示得很好。哈哈哈哈。
Nicely done. Yeah, she shows up in season two. So you did, you made it to two seasons out of eight. All right, well. Ha. Anyway. Yeah. Ha ha ha.
干得漂亮。对，她在第二季出场了。所以你确实看了，八季里你看了两季。好吧，总之。哈。不管怎样。对。哈哈哈哈。
House of Dragons is about dragons. They're a big part of it. Obviously, they're in the title. What I'm saying is I did not know that riding on the dragons was a thing. House of Dragons, you know what? They just kind of meander on the field by the castle. How is that gonna sound on it?
《龙之家族》是关于龙的。它们是其中的重要部分。很显然，它们就在剧名里。我的意思是，我不知道骑龙是这么回事。《龙之家族》，你知道吗？它们就只是在城堡旁边的田野里溜达。这听起来会怎么样？
Obviously, the dragons are going to fly. I didn't know they had people on them. OK. OK. That's fair. That's fair. It's fair. No.
很显然，龙是会飞的。我不知道它们背上有人。好吧。好吧。这倒也合理。这倒也合理。挺合理的。不。
No, Sam's not having it. No. It's not fair. There's another story I was not expecting to tell today. Well, listen, everybody. We love you so much. We will see you next week for AARM Part 1. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
不，萨姆不买账。不。这不合理。这是我今天没料到要讲的另一个故事。好吧，听着，各位。我们非常爱你们。我们下周再见，届时将播出 AARM 第一部分。再见。谢谢收听 Office Ladies。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Office Ladies 是 Odyssey 的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Odyssey 的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。Office Ladies 的混音和母带制作由克里斯·巴塞尔完成。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。你目前还没有这集的评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。